una de las herramientas más usadas en
estadística es la noción del puntaje z
podemos pensar en un puntaje z como el
número de desviaciones estándar lejos de
la media de la población a la que se
encuentra un dato particular ahora
veamos un ejemplo para que esto nos
quede más claro imaginemos que somos
biólogos marinos y acabamos de descubrir
una nueva especie de tortuga alada la
población de tortugas aladas que
descubrimos tiene siete tortugas así que
vamos y medimos a todas nos interesa la
longitud y cómo se distribuye esta
longitud así que lo escribimos aquí
longitud de las tortugas aladas en
centímetros son unas tortugas muy
pequeñas anotamos las mediciones y
tenemos una tortuga de dos centímetros
otra de dos centímetros una tortuga de
tres centímetros una de dos centímetros
tenemos una más grande de cinco
centímetros ahora tenemos una muy
chiquitita de un centímetro y por último
tenemos a la más grande de todas que es
de 6 centímetros estos son todos
nuestros datos y los invito a qué pausa
en el vídeo en cualquier momento que
ustedes quieran
a calcular por su cuenta cuál es la
media de la población suponiendo que
esta es toda la población de tortugas
aladas recordemos que la media la
calculamos al sumar todos los datos y
luego al dividir el resultado entre el
número de datos que tenemos si sumamos
todos estos números y los dividimos
entre 7 nos va a dar 3 y ahora con estos
mismos datos y la media de la población
podemos calcular la desviación estándar
de la población si quieren pueden pausar
el vídeo y calcularlo ustedes mismos
pero yo ya lo hice desde antes y la
desviación estándar de la población es
aproximadamente 1.69 si redondeamos a la
centésima más cercana ahora sí con toda
esta información ya podemos calcular el
puntaje z para cada uno de los datos
pausa en el vídeo y vean si pueden
hacerlo vamos a poner una columna para
los puntajes z si vemos la definición lo
que vamos a hacer para cada uno de los
datos es si llamamos x al dato a
analizar vamos a restarle la media y
vamos a dividir el resultado entre la
desviación estándar este numerador nos
indica qué tan lejos estamos
por arriba o por abajo de la media pero
queremos saber cuántas desviaciones
estándar estamos alejados de la media y
es por eso que dividimos esto entre la
desviación estándar de la población
veamos el primer dato cuál será su
puntaje z tomamos el dato que es 2 luego
le restamos la media que es 3 y
dividimos el resultado entre 1.69 que es
la desviación estándar es menos 1 / 1.69
y si usan la calculadora verán que esto
es aproximadamente igual a menos 0.59 el
puntaje z de este segundo dato va a ser
el mismo
- 0.59 esta cantidad la podemos
interpretar como un poco más de media
desviación estándar por abajo de la
media podemos hacer lo mismo para datos
que están por arriba de la media por
ejemplo éste 6 pausa en el vídeo y
traten de calcular su puntaje z
va a ser igual a 6 menos la media que es
3 / 1.69 que es la desviación estándar
si tienen calculadora verán que esto es
aproximadamente igual a 1.77 yo ya hice
este cálculo de antemano esto quiere
decir que está a más de una pero a menos
de dos desviaciones estándar por arriba
de la media
ahora los invito a que ustedes calculen
los puntajes z para los datos que faltan
quizá algunos de ustedes se estén
haciendo la siguiente pregunta obvia
porque porque nos interesa saber a
cuántas desviaciones estándar por arriba
o por abajo de la media está cierto dato
y pues en sus cursos de estadística
verán que el puntaje z es una forma muy
útil de darnos cuenta de qué tan común o
poco común es cierto dato y eso va a ser
muy valioso cuando comencemos a hacer
inferencias con base de los datos hasta
aquí vamos a ver este tema pero tengan
en mente que el puntaje z es una idea
muy útil y a la vez es muy sencilla si
conocemos la media y la desviación
estándar entonces podemos tomar un dato
restarle la media
tiene el resultado entre la desviación
estándar y con eso habremos encontrado
su puntaje z nos vemos en el siguiente
vídeo